"IT Chapter Two" is one of this year's
most anticipated films and a lot of people
are excited for the return of the movie's
creepy child-murdering clown, Pennywise.
(audience cheers)
Well, ladies and gentlemen,
there is one group of people
who are definitely not excited
Real clowns, okay?
(audience laughs)
Yes, they say the "IT" movie promotes
negative views of clowns.
So, with us tonight, yeah,
there's always someone,
with us tonight is
someone who wants to speak
on behalf of the outraged clown community.
Please welcome Butterscotch the Clown,
let's get him out here.
(organ music)
(audience cheering)
Hello, hello, San Diego!
Hi Conan.
(giggling)
All right, well, yeah, yeah,
hello there, Butterscotch.
So, I guess clowns are pretty unhappy
about how the new It
movie portrays clowns.
You bet we are!
Pennywise makes clowns
look like creepy monsters,
when most of us clowns are
actually sweet and cuddly.
Like me!
(creepy music)
(audience laughing)
(giggling creepily)
Okay, yeah, I--
(audience laughing)
I understand your
frustration, Butterscotch.
So, did you come to Comic-Con®
to protest this movie, It?
Oh no, I'm here all week at Comic-Con®
to spread the message
that clowns are nice.
In fact, I've been driving
this van around all week.
Oh, okay, in San Diego?
(audience laughing)
Wait, oh my God, it says,
who wants to eat babies?!
(laughs) Oops!
Some letters must have fallen off.
It says, who wants to 12 seats for babies?
(audience laughs)
Wait, well, wait a minute,
well, why are you giving away baby seats?
Well, giving away slightly used baby seats
that mysteriously ended
up in my possession
is a great way to connect with families
and let them know I
won't murder their kids.
(audience laughs)
I mean,
I won't murder their kids!
(audience laughs)
I won't murder--
Who likes birthday parties?!
(giggles)
(audience cheering)
I don't know.
I don't know what this has
to do with the movie It,
but sure, Butterscotch,
I guess we all like birthday parties.
Ooh, then I got the
birthday clown for you.
Me!
Okay.
You see, I believe every
child's last birthday
deserves to be special!
(audience laughing)
Which is why I let the
birthday boy or girl
spin my wheel of funtivities!
Bring in the fun wheel!
(organ music)
All right, let's get
the fun wheel in here,
ladies and gentlemen, here it is.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Yes, look at all the fun
we can have together!
Yess.
Wait a minute, hold on,
it says Russian roulette.
Yes! (giggling)
Harass the eel, that is very strange.
10 minute slow dance?
Oh, that's a fun one.
No, no, no, and what's this right here?
It's just a bunch of symbols.
Oh yes, that summons Prince Hogoroth,
the eater of screams!
(audience laughs)
Let's hope it doesn't land on that one!
Now spin the fun wheel!
All right, well, I'll
give a shot right here,
I'll give a little spin.
(wheel clicking)
Round and round the fun wheel goes,
round and round, where it stops, nobody--
Okay, a little confused about this.
(audience laughs)
Knows, woo-hoo!
Okay, I'm confused, it
says animal balloons.
Yes.
Don't you mean
balloon animals?
Oh, you'll wish I did.
(audience laughs)
I make all sorts of animal balloons
by finding flat little
fellas near the highway,
then filling them with helium!
(audience laughing)
(creepy music)
See?
I found this possum near the I-5 on-let.
That's a possum?!
Yes, it used to be.
Oh.
And here's a snake I
made into a dog balloon!
Ruff ruff!
(audience laughing)
Hiss hiss!
Okay, you know what?
I think you've wasted enough of our time.
Agree to disagree!
All right.
Before I leave, I just want to say
please don't come to
Comic-Con® in Pennywise cosplay
when there are so many
other fun cosplay ideas
that don't glamorize
child-murdering clowns.
All right.
(audience laughs)
Here's a great one!
Look familiar, Conan?
(organ music)
Oh wow, yeah, of course.
It's Hello Kitty.
(audience cheering)
Yes, exactly!
What a cute, sweet idea
for cosplay at Comic-Con®!
And I got all the details right,
she's even anatomically correct.
Huh?
(audience laughing)
(cats mewling)
Drink up, little kitties!
Drink up, little ones!
(suckling)
That's really, I don't,
no one, no, no one wants--
Are you thirsty, Conan?
No, I'm not thirsty.
And no one wants to see that.
(audience laughing)
Okay.
That's really not good.
Here's another great cosplay idea
for fans of science fiction!
Recognize this classic character, Conan?
I'm not sure,
I guess it's just some
kind of astronaut, huh?
Ooh, well maybe this will jog your memory.
(screaming)
(screeching)
(audience laughing)
Peek-a-boo!
You see, it's the
crotch-burster from Aliens!
(giggling)
Now, who wants to see
me make him spit acid?!
(audience cheers)
Now wait a minute,
wait a minute, no!
C'mon!
No!
I just have to choke him
a little!
No, we don't, no, no, no--
I just have to choke him
a little bit like this!
No, no, no!
(audience cheering)
Spurt the acid!
No, no, no, get away, get away, get away!
No, no!
Tickle his stomach while I choke him!
Yeah, no, I'm not going to.
No?
Butterscotch the Clown, everybody,
we have a lot more show coming up.